riots in the Iraqi city of Basra have
left 12 people dead mass rallies against
government corruption have been
escalating over the past few days on
Thursday the fourth day of the protests
people torched government buildings into
the night the riots erupted as the
country's politicians struggle to form a
new government
people are also protesting about a lack
of basic basic services such as water
and electricity they say that the city's
water supply is contaminated with
hundreds needing hospital treatment
after drinking it while power cuts are
frequent security forces were dispersing
the crowds with tear gas and according
to the city's health officials with live
rounds
[Applause]
[Music]
we have if somebody is trying to add
fuel to the fire to damage the
relationship between the security forces
and the people I've ordered an
investigation you find out what is going
on and who is behind it
political commentator a deal Darwish
says the government should be doing much
more to address the concerns of
protesters
it's a rooted deeply rooted corruption
which actually result in poor
maintenance and as well as lacking of
basic services they are unable to form a
government in order at least to present
the someone responsible that protesters
actually can address their grievances to
and I don't see any body coming with
seen workable idea Israeli tragic for a
country like Iran I would actually make
a public speech I would call the
security forces back and just say let's
all call for calm
I haven't heard this kind of speech from
the Iraqi Prime Minister so it's going
to be deepened division between the
security forces whose supposed to
protect the people and the people
themselves
you